der sechste januar 2021 hat die welt
schockiert doch all das hat sich lange
angekündigt und die spuren führen ins
netz nachdem reitz in washington hatte
ich eine woche lang recherchiert ich
habe mir die nächte in den wirklich
dunklen ecken des internets um die ohren
gehauen paar sachen gelesen die mir
angst gemacht haben und mit den
extremisten gesprochen über die gerade
die ganzen usa diskutieren ich werde mit
einem kraut sprechen und so viel schon
mal vorab an die ranzukommen ist gerade
alles andere als einfach
aber fangen wir vorne an bei der wurzel
des problems seit monaten twitter trump
von einer gestohlenen war stoppte stil
geht die ral und seine anhänger
mobilisieren hashtag mega make it rain
again wird zum schlachtruf online und
offline und schließlich erobert ein
wütender mob das herz der amerikanischen
demokratie und die welt ist dank social
media und dem hashtag storm bekämpfte
live dabei
der journalist brannten guten schwager
dokumentiert seit monaten die wut der
protestbewegung im land von trump demos
bis zu black gleisbett auch bei dem
sturm aufs capitol war er mittendrin
um seine bilder ging um die welt
[Musik]
wir sprechen
aufgeteilt durch trans rede setzen sich
seine anhänger richtung kapitol in
bewegung und hier entleert sich die
wochenlange stimmungsmache im netz auf
ein schlag
[Musik]
renten war von anfang an mit seiner
kamera mitten drin und stellt die bilder
auf twitter online
in the social network
aber social media wird auch und
besonders zur stimmungsmache genutzt
auch das zeigen die bilder aus dießen
der sturm aufs kapital ein online event
wie viele babys mertes wird dünner
gepäck in objective social media
beim blick ins netz wird klar seit
monaten wird auf alternativen sozialen
netzwerken und in foren mobilisiert
wütende trump fans kein anhänger und
andere verschwörungs ideologen machen
ihr stimmung gegen den staat aber auch
paramilitärische rechtsextreme gruppen
wie die auf keepers die free press
centers oder die bungalows formieren
sich und natürlich die nationalistischen
braut weiß ob und wie diese gruppen mit
dem sturm auf das kapitol in verbindung
stehen wird jetzt fbi klären müssen ich
spreche mit dem sicherheitsexperten
emerson blocking der das fbi schon lange
vor dem 6 januar gewarnt hatte in den
foren und sozialen netzwerken treffen
diese gruppen zusammen
es entsteht auf den explosiver cocktail
aus gefährlichen ideologien
[Musik]
diese ecke kemmers das in netzwerke wie
parlak fortune oder beton der in diesen
netzwerken gepostet die innerhalb wird
gar nicht über oft nur sehr lax
reguliert die plattform verstehen sich
als festung der freedom of speech
so viel wird schnell klar extremismus
florian der sechs januar zeigt auf
eindrucksvolle weise was passiert wenn
der hass aus dem netz auf einmal in die
reale welt überschwappt und dabei
spielen auch diese alternativen sozialen
netzwerke eine wichtige rolle und es
wirklich zu verstehen muss ich da
irgendwie selbst rein
ich beginne auf dem gerade populärsten
alternativen social network besonders
die rechte bruderschaft preis scheint
hier eine macht
ich will kontakt zu ihnen aufnehmen aber
um ihn nachrichten senden zu können muss
ich mich erst verifizieren mit
ausweisung webcam ganz ehrlich hier
seine personalausweis nummer einzugeben
das fühlt sich nicht gut an
was meint ihr könntet ihr euch das bei
facebook oder instagram vorstellen
nach anfragen an 20 braut post chapter
wurde mir bis jetzt nur dix angeboten
was sind das für typen
um das besser zu verstehen sprechen mit
christa fasst jörg vom institut
d'astrophysique dialogue in london
der untersucht schon lange das online
verhalten von extrem ist innen hält
groups und besonders den traut boys
[Musik]
neun jahre nach dem gipfel mcinnis weiß
verlassen hat gründet er 2016 die braut
boys
das erfolgsrezept der rein männlichen
bruderschaft gruppengefühl nationalismus
und eine prise sagt hast mich
[Applaus]
die profis bezeichnen sich selbst als
western shoppings und sagen sie seien
and traces aber gleichzeitig and
immigration and tired and political
correctness und pro ganz und wie stellen
die westliche kultur über alles
[Applaus]
[Musik]
um besonders brutale auseinandersetzung
in verbindung mit dem gleis meta
protesten und der antifa netz haben sie
und ihre idee gut und bekannt gemacht
bis in die höchsten ebenen der politik
[Musik]
wird es live tv duells mit joe biden im
wahlkampf 2020 richtet sich trump direkt
an die gruppe die rolle der braut beim
sturm ops capitol ist weiter umstritten
ich will sie auf keinen fall
verharmlosen aber möglichst
unvoreingenommen mit ihm sprechen
ich will ihnen so nahe kommen wie das
von ihr per skype leben geht und ich
kann es kaum glauben messi wollte hier
in orange neben dem anführer trio ist
tatsächlich bereit mit ihm zu sprechen
es ist zwei uhr nachts 19 uhr ortszeit
in tennessee usa
wir wollen sky ob wir wirklich dran geht
wenn ich den gleichen anrufe bin
gespannt
matthew ist chef der präsident aus
tennessee und spricht tatsächlich mit
mir über die profis
hier wird noch einmal klar die
organisation funktioniert über
gemeinschaft und den gemeinsamen kampf
das zeigt sich ein bisschen die
drohungen und das aggressive auftreten
auf social media laut matthew alles nur
show matthew city schuld also bei den
linken
das passt ins boot denn auch der kampf
gegen links und die antifa ist für die
potters elementar
[Applaus]
[Musik]
trump und viele andere rechte in fluren
samtrot boys wurden von den mainstream
social media plattform verbannt und auch
ihre zufluchtsorte wurde mittlerweile
wegen zuviel hate speech vom server
betreiber der stecker gezogen
das netz gespalten wie das land nur bei
einem scheinen sich alle einig amerika
ist in gefahr
[Musik]
steckt dahinter auch eine warnung ganz
ehrlich ich kann es nicht sagen
fest steht vier jahre unter trump haben
das land nicht nur tief gespalten
sondern auch extremistischen
gruppierungen wie dem hauptpreis eine
neue bühne geboten
im netz und auch ganz real washington
ist seit diesem 6 januar nicht mehr
dasselbe
die angst ist groß dass dies ist der
anfang war und dass sich die
aggressionen über den amtswechsel hinaus
fortsetzen werden
am ende bleibt für mich die frage was
man gegen den hass im netz machen kann
brauchen wir mehr kontrolle und welche
verantwortung tragen die plattformen auf
denen das ganze passiert was meint ihr
dazu schreibt mir doch eure meinung in
die kommentare
dann können wir diskutieren das war es
von mir bis bald
[Musik]